So if we think of the deep ocean
as being this dark,
deep, horrifying place
at the bottom of the Earth,
it's easy to dismiss it as something
which is out of sight and out of mind.
But myself and colleagues have been there,
and I think if we take some time
to think about the deep ocean
as part of our planet,
we all might want to protect it
as much as any other marine environment.
Let your imagination tell you
what a deep-sea animal looks like.
The one that immediately flashes
into your head when you think deep sea.
You're probably thinking
something like this.
(Laughter)
And that is a real fish.
That's a real animal from the deep sea.
Now, that's the kind of image
you are quite often presented with
in the media when we talk
about deep-water animals.
But there's two things wrong
with that photograph.
First one, it's a little bit
misleading in that
those types of animals
are generally quite shallowish
in the grand scheme of things,
maybe a few hundred meters,
certainly top thousand meters.
The second thing
that's a little bit misleading
is that they are normally about that big.
(Laughter)
Right? So they're hardly that scary.
It's not going to come and get you, is it?
But we are forever being told
that there are "monsters of the deep"
in a low voice,
and aliens of the abyss.
But when you take a moment
to think about the technicalities
of being an alien in the abyss,
the only alien in the deep sea
are the occasional human.
Because everything else belongs there.
So I am proud to say
I am an alien of the abyss.
(Laughter)
And I've been studying the deepest
parts of the ocean for 20 years,
but more recently,
we've been diving in a submarine.
One of the questions
you quite often get asked
when you tell someone,
"Oh, Tuesday, I went to 10,000 meters,"
they say, "Ooh, isn't that scary?"
And that is the important
point, it's fear.
It's that thing that we have in our heads
that doesn't like being underwater.
So if you think about what
the deep sea represents,
it's a physical,
three-dimensional manifestation
of two of the things we hate the most.
And we have a phrase for that.
We call it the deepest, darkest fears.
Because we are air-breathing mammals.
So we don't really want to be underwater,
especially not super deep.
And we're visually orientated
animals, we like light.
But 11 kilometers underwater
is something that everyone goes,
"Ah, that's really deep and horrible.
That's just frightening."
Take that 11 kilometers
and turn it on its side.
I reckon most people in the room
have traveled 11 kilometers today.
And the other thing
that we don't like is the unknown.
And this is where we get
into this whole relationship
between reality
and what we're told on the TV.
So on the TV, we're quite regularly told
that we know more
about the surface of the Moon
than we know about the deep sea.
For starters, that quote goes back
before the Apollo missions
and a time where we knew not very much
about the Moon or the deep sea.
So if you're on the surface
and you're looking out
and you can see all these lovely whales
and dolphins and squid and jellyfish,
all that stuff has to die.
All that material,
all that lovely organic matter sinks.
And where does it sink?
It sinks down to deeper depths.
It ends up in the place we call the abyss.
And not "the abyss" like they say on TV.
The abyssal zone technically are depths
between 3,000 and 6,000 meters.
OK, relatively shallow in my game.
All that lovely organic material
comes down and settles there.
And it gets eaten by deep-sea animals.
Those deep-sea animals are eating it,
they're recycling it, they're burning it.
They’re incorporating into the food chain,
and they incorporate it
into the sediments.
So these animals are essentially gardening
because if they didn't do that,
these big, vast abyssal
plains of the planet
would become big,
stagnant, horrible cesspits.
So the deep-sea animals are basically
irrigating a big chunk of the planet.
And I say a big chunk.
The abyssal zones account
for about 70 percent of the planet.
Let's take a bit of a journey,
a descent into the deep sea.
How do we know where to dive?
How do we know where we are ever?
Because we're always being told ...
(Laughter)
No, it's true, we're always being told
that we haven't mapped the oceans.
A certain amount of seafloor
has been seen with the naked eye.
I took that with my phone.
(Laughter)
So I was seeing it at the same time.
So it still counts.
And there's a certain percentage
which has been mapped
or surveyed by remote systems.
So this is about 2,000 meters deep.
And about 20 percent of the planet
has been mapped in pretty high
resolution using acoustics.
This is a huge, big trench
running off north of New Zealand.
Well, basically they have been mapped.
It all depends on what resolution.
OK so there's some places where we know
where absolutely every little
nook and cranny might be.
There are no more
Mariana Trenches to be found.
Imagine we're in our submarine,
this is us diving in the submarine,
see, it's very spacious.
It has all the latest mod cons,
the sunlight diminishes very,
very quickly in the top,
maybe in the first two minutes.
It goes that fast and you see
that it does get dark very quickly.
And as we descend down
through the water column,
we're always being told
that the water is very, very cold.
Very, very icy cold water.
And yeah, it's cold.
It's not anywhere near as cold as most,
if not all of the winters I've ever
endured until moving to Australia.
(Laughter)
It's about between one
and two degrees at deepest point.
It's not overly cold.
But those water masses
deep down are still moving,
they're still ventilating,
they're still full of oxygen
and they're moving heat.
They're pulling heat down
from the atmosphere and the surface waters
and dissipating it around the planet.
And as we go down the bottom
of the Mariana Trench,
we now have one ton
per square centimeter of pressure
squeezing down on that
titanium ball we’re sat in.
Again, it takes a certain person
of a certain disposition to do this stuff,
but you can’t feel it on the inside,
it’s fine, it’s cold outside.
And we’re moving around,
and if you look out the window,
we're looking mostly at mud.
Imagine all that stuff
that has come down from the surface.
All that lovely organic matter.
It's carbon, it's taking carbon
from the atmosphere,
it's being absorbed into the ocean.
The surface of oceans basically comes
down and sinks into the mud.
What happens to the carbon?
The bottom of the trenches,
the reason why the trenches are so deep,
the reason why they're
11 kilometers in some places
is because two tectonic plates
hit each other.
Sometimes they get pulled apart,
sometimes they slide side by side.
But the trenches are formed
when one tectonic plate hits another one
and drives it down
into the Earth’s mantle.
Hence you end up with something
like Mariana Trench.
Now all that carbon
trapped in the sediment
is now being pushed back
into the Earth’s mantle.
The deepest points on the planet
are one of the few places
where we're actually disposing of carbon.
So they're again, performing
a service to the planet.
So when looking out the window,
what's it look like?
(Laughter)
If you switch your lights on,
right, it looks like mud.
You have a lot of places
that are very flat.
Lovely, luscious, golden-brown.
That's a good, healthy sea floor, OK.
Sometimes you see some rocks
and some rocky outcrops.
You see cobbles and rocks and boulders.
Sometimes it's a bit crazy.
But none of these images look that weird.
They look like something
you would expect to see
if you were scuba diving at night.
So the actual visual landscape
of the deepest places
isn't that strange either,
it's certainly not something
you should fear.
So let's get back
to the monsters of the deep.
What do you reckon the deepest
tentacled animal is in the world?
Bear in mind, it's the tentacles
that have been putting the fear of God
into sailors since I don't know when.
Imagine “The Thing” coming up
from the deep sea.
So you're probably thinking
something a little bit like that.
(Laughter)
That's also a picture I took
on my phone recently.
(Laughter)
It's been a funny old week.
That's ...
That’s the kind of image
your imagination puts into your head
when you think deep sea, tentacles
and the rest of it.
The reality of the matter is --
and I can proudly say that I discovered
the deepest octopus in the world --
Audience: Aw.
AJ: It’s the size of a puppy, too.
(Laughter)
It gets better.
Its real name is Grimpoteuthis,
which is a bit “rurr.”
But its common name is Dumbo Octopus
because it has big Dumbo-like ears.
And this lives at close to 7,000
metres in the Indian Ocean.
That is your big, scary octopus
that's coming to get you.
So then we think about what's
the deepest fish look like.
Because they've got big,
horrible fangs, right?
And they're lurking in the darkness,
coming to get you.
Deepest fish in the world
is actually what we call a snailfish.
If anything, it's a bit goofy-looking.
It's not really that threatening.
It's not something you should fear.
They're snuffling around,
they're looking for stuff
and they've got little eyes,
they're actually gelatinous,
that's its liver you can see
on the side of its body.
They're very soft-bodied.
And what I really love
about the deepest fish in the world
is they’re not really deep-sea fish.
They're actually a shallow water family
that has just radiated.
Most snailfish
are actually really shallow,
you even get some in estuaries.
It's just a fish that doesn't care,
you can't pigeonhole the snailfish.
So ...
Another animal ... that we
like are prawns, right?
Everyone loves to eat a prawn.
That there is the last, the deepest
of the big crustaceans.
That's a prawn, and those
are down to nearly 8,000 metres.
And that wouldn't look
that out of place in a fish market.
There's nothing weird about it either.
And one of my personal favorites
from the very, very, deepest points,
and we see these bizarrely at the very
deepest points in multiple trenches,
we very rarely see them anywhere else
except for the most extreme places.
And it's a type of anemone.
And they just kind of look
like white flowers floating in the wind.
They’re actually really beautiful animals,
and they’re living in, unbelievably,
what we would class as being
extreme environments.
They have an unpronounceable Latin name,
which I maybe shouldn't try,
but it's Galatheanthemum.
I've done it.
(Laughter and applause)
Thank you.
(Applause)
I'm not doing it again, though,
I got away with it once.
So if you start to rethink
the visual imagery
and the way in which
the deep sea is in reality
and not the way we're told,
it's time that we started thinking
about the oceans generally
as just one big ocean,
from its surface to the bottom.
The ocean doesn't recognize
imaginary lines that we've drawn
and said that's sea, that's deep sea.
So we care, don't care.
Care, don't care, right?
And that's actually what we do.
You wouldn't turn up in the Amazon,
and say, "Right, everyone,
We're going to catalog every known species
for the first 200 meters,
everything after that
are monsters of the trees."
(Laughter)
"Because it's just dark and horrible
in there, so let's not do that."
But that is exactly what we do right now
to 70 percent of the planet.
And that's what I find quite frustrating.
Another question I get asked
sometimes as well is --
other than the fear stuff,
and the claustrophobia
and the toilet question
and stuff like that --
is, you know, what’s it like being
in the bottom of the sea,
looking out the window and seeing stuff?
And I actually find it a genuinely
difficult question to answer.
Because it’s quite exciting.
Afterwards, you’re like,
“Ooh, that was really exciting.”
But at the time, it’s quite humbling.
Because I think you’re kind of
aware of the fact
you’re seven miles underwater
and one ton per square centimeter
and all that kind of,
you do feel quite remote.
But I just think it looks
kind of majestic.
I think it's certainly
the exact polar opposite
of what you're told it should be like.
It’s not scary, it’s peaceful,
and it’s nice, and there’s beauty there.
And I think we need to challenge
the narratives that we are given
and change the story
and start to think of the deep sea
as a place which is fascinating,
it's wonderful, it's interesting,
and it's really, really important.
And only at that point,
if we take all that on board
will we ever truly,
truly protect and live
alongside our oceans.
Thank you.
(Applause)